Dutch mover is a novel visio haptic
device that Co locates immersive 3d
stereo visualization direct touch and
touch force sensing with a robotic li
actuated display touch mover is capable
of providing movement and force feedback
in a single dimension perpendicular to
the screen plane the user can touch and
press on the screen to move it to the
desired location the on-screen visuals
are updated with the movement of the
screen which creates a compelling 3d
immersive experience
to demonstrate the interactive
capabilities of touch mover we designed
for different example applications first
we created a 3d physical simulation with
force feedback the user can interact
with the on-screen 3d object and
experience different force responses
from the physical simulation for example
the stone block on the left is much
harder to move than the sponge block on
the right the stereo convergence plane
is set to be at the screen depth which
means that the objects being touched are
always rendered with zero parallax for
the user in contrast to the previous non
moving stereo touchscreen solutions
touch mover ensures that the depth of
the screen plane the users finger and
the virtual 3d object all match
in addition to providing force-feedback
our system allows the user to feel the
contour of a rigid 3d object by
physically moving the screen based on
the fingers location on the display for
example the user feels the surface of a
ball while the display haptically
renders its surface contours touch mover
can also be used to annotate
interactions with 2d data we implemented
a volumetric medical image viewer which
allows for the browsing through slices
of MRI brain scan data by pushing
through the layers the user can also
touch a button on the side to lock the
screen in place and annotate the slice
with their finger to facilitate easier
search and retrieval of annotated slices
our device creates a haptic detent when
the user reaches an annotated slice this
haptic detent pauses the movement of the
screen when an annotated slice is
encountered by applying a slightly
larger force navigation is continued
finally we demonstrate how haptic
feedback get enhanced even the simplest
touchscreen interactions for example to
reduce deletion error repro to type
custom buttons that activate based on
screen movement with different
resistances this solution can make it
very difficult to trigger important
buttons by accident
we tested the ability of touch mover to
convey 3d shape information through the
haptic channel in our study participants
were asked to identify 10 3d shapes
without having explicit visual feedback
shown on the screen then after each
trial the shape was visually revealed to
the participant our study showed that
the participant successfully identified
85% of the shapes correctly in less than
a minute per shape for more findings
please refer to the paper
in summary touch mover device is a novel
vizio haptic platform designed to
explore the use of haptic sensations in
touchscreens of the future